so the first one you want to know about
was the 91 year old who got gored by a
bull so um it's just such a ridiculous
sentence a 91 year old got glorified
like how do you go 91 years on this
rocket outer space and then wait to get
Gore by a bull it just doesn't make any
difference he was like some Farm guy and
for some reason he got in a pen with the
bull and the bull won I mean hit broke
arms broke all the ribs on one side of
his body at 90. here's the thing that's
a these are devastating injuries for a
teenager or someone in their 20s that
could that could take a bit of a beating
91 and the unfortunate part about that
was the family wasn't ready to let him
go like they were crying
it's not
the Honeydew with y'all subscribe today